[Applaudissements]
alors ça te rappelle chevallier il nous
avait manqué ce week-end c'est les
génies du passous le dis et pour débuter
avec classe on va commencer avec la
bataille des coupes alors je vous
explique les chevaliers les tests ritter
si vous ne connaissez pas encore je
rappelle le concept ce sont des
candidats qui partent sur une île pour
tester la solidité de leur couple et en
faisant des épreuves et 100% du temps ça
finit en mode benjamin castaldi c'est de
la diva ce lundi je vous dis d'auray
grave pour maxime et alizée c'est un des
couples c'est le moment fatidique du
vote pour savoir quel couple va quitter
l'aventuré est évidemment maximaliser se
sont en danger
alors nos tourtereaux cogiter nous
explique clairement leur stratégie le
problème c'est qu'à passer bac plus sept
options bataille des coupes c'est la
meilleure amie de mel donc
automatiquement est-ce que dylan la
tuile la famille emmanuel nous avait
demandé à nous et amel ouais tu vois
deux dominés mais elle a accepté alors
qu'elle est en alliance avec fanny et
mamies peut-être qu'elle l'a elle peut
accepter même si elle en a bien cru ne
voudra jamais dassier veut pas dire j
mais non non non non je crois pas j'ai
rien compris
la spécialiste week-end un couple qui
avait été très critiquée sur les réseaux
sociaux lors de leur passage pour
pourquoi vous regarder pendant pékin
express ah oui c'est très copiés ils ont
fait peu cas l'explication
ouais et ils se sont retrouvés là bas
ben c'est ce que je me disais enfin
gilbert savoir quelle saison prochaine
il va voir isabelle morini bosc
ça nous a révélé pas là aujourd'hui
parce qu'elle est en train de faire le
casting il faut se poser les bonnes
questions alors s'ils gainent la
bataille des gaines
[Rires]
non
[Applaudissements]
sortez allez faire un tour vous allez
voir vous verrez vous allez voir si je
suis là bas allez si vous ne comprenez
pas tout ce que disent les candidats de
la bataille des couples et des
marseillais contre le reste du monde pas
de panique c'est juste parce que vous ne
parlez peut-être pas la même langue
voici donc un petit récapitulatif des
nouveaux mots qu'on a appris ce week-end
grâce à nous n attention je vous dis des
vacances viennent de commencer je sais
qu'il ya beaucoup d'enfants qui nous
regardent
je rappelle que ces mots sont utilisés
par des professionnels
[Rires]
n'essayez pas de les réutiliser à
l'école regardez
[Musique]
cook est en aussi cédé calme et de
temporiser la chose mais on va changer
la formule 1 qu'une chose en vie c'est
un bar avec ma femme et les laisser tous
dans leur hypocrisie et alors focus cité
absolue c'est la première cérémonie où
on sait que les votes sont contre nous
donc on a juste le petit espoir qu'elle
soit nantes éliminatoires et combative
une arrivée en force âge c'est terminé
on n'a pas l'anecdote elle pas pouvoir
revenir en arrière
on ne fera pas le vaccin c'est l'anti de
sa série qui ne captait bien ton cou
est-ce que tu poses des questions sur l
éventualité de célibataires rien non
je les adore je les ai je les adore
ils font évoluer la langue bah oui mais
c'est important je vous le dis est ce
que vous connaissez patrick sauce non
non matrix hausse alors c'est un envoyé
spécial de bfm
et c'est devenu mon nouveau héros de
chez eux vous le savez la nouvelle mode
chez les manifestants
senna lui est reconnue mais le
journaliste pendant ses ex généralement
les envoyés spéciaux n'ose pas trop
intervenir sauf un
c'est patrick sauce et apparemment la
moutarde lui monter au nez
enfin regarder presque ému pardonner
même moi j'avais simplement leçon de
michel barnier par forcément le la
vision vous voyez qu'un petit peu de
bousculade parce que les les principaux
responsables sont en train d'arriver
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on peut le revoir regardez regardez même
moi j'avais simplement leçon de michel
barnier par forcément le la vision wiki
un petit peu de bousculade parce que les
les principaux responsables sont en
train d'arriver
merci
[Applaudissements]
déjà énervé à l'antenne voir moment
voilà c'est un truc qui vous a énervé à
l'antenne mais non je ne crois pas non
au castaldi ne compte pas ça a dû
m'arriver ou est sur la radio sur le lot
oui bien sûr qu'est ce qui sépare oui
oui je me souviens je me suis énervé
parce qu'en fait on qu'on avait il ya la
fameuse enveloppe qui est qui arrivait
tout temps à la fin d'émission pour
savoir qui est éliminée et on avait
invité deux humoristes à l'époque trop
de nombreuses carrières et franchit pas
eu à huy s'était amené le quick et
flupke est en fait ils ont fait un très
curieux ils ont pris mon enveloppe
ah ouais je me rappelle est bon c'est
pas la page et où je me suis énervé et
je suis passé à côté de la séquence qui
a fait rire tout le monde sauf moi
évidemment oui décennale et soupe au
lait et c'était un copain c'est le bout
sur m6 est les fuck quoi exciter un
animateur est arrivé sur ces 8 il a pris
2,3 thann et ça l'a calmé mais l'état
n'est pas tarder à tout le monde mais
surtout si m
[Applaudissements]
la plus sérieuse à tout le monde
montador ça dans l'épaule alors à
l'appui bat en ce nouvel avis attention
gros scoop une nouvelle voyante à
démarquer sur id voyance par l a déjà
été très impressionnant pour sa première
consultation je vous dis regardez bien
je vous jure chez vous aucun trucage
vous allez voir là vous allez être
bluffé regardez déménagé de paris champs
déménagement aujourd'hui c'est un signe
alors déménagé pas de paris d'accord là
vous habitez où exactement
j'en dis papa
la ceni c'est bon elle habite à paris sa
geôle s est senti ça il ya un truc que
j'ai remarqué ce week-end sur la chaîne
idf1 parce que je regarde beaucoup idf
c'est que le téléspectateur est roi
vraiment sur cette chaîne
mais alors en même temps c'est normal
parce que le téléspectateur au roi est
roi parce qu'il n'y en a qu'un seul
quand le seul mec de la journée appel
pour jouer ça avait ajouté des fois n'y
a qu'un mec qu'a peine
emma c'est lui qui décide des règles du
jeu il décide de tout c'est lui qui
décide des choix des chansons et en plus
en plus il y voilà que même quand il est
saoul et je prend même plus la tête j'ai
dit ni comment je dois raccrocher merci
au revoir garde
du coup vous nous appelez pour l'instant
mystère
[Musique]
non c'est vrai reconnaît d un petit
sardou un petit jeu connaissant comme
quoi me direz que ça va oui oui allez
quoi l'on parle de quoi y'a une voyante
qui se demandaient latella loupé de
balle est restée au bout quelle est la
plus stable et la banque a dit qu'il
habitait à paris
quand je suis un malade mental je sais
plus à baida toile et l'individu ait pas
grand chose il a cinq minutes de retard
salois beurre et saufs